y
[Música]
europa enfrenta la segunda ola de hobbit
19 mientras se acercan las fiestas
navideñas
varios países han impuesto nuevas
restricciones entre ellos suiza italia
españa y reino unido- donde más de 20
millones de ciudadanos han tenido que
aislarse debido al descubrimiento de una
nueva cepa del virus considerada
altamente contagiosa el impacto
económico de la decisión será severo
según el ministro de salud británico
méxico registró más de 12.000 contagios
y 627 muertes en las últimas 24 horas
las cifras se producen pese a que este
sábado fue el primer día de cierre de
comercios no esenciales en la capital y
en el estado de mexico la restricción
que afecta fuertemente a los
comerciantes no impidió una importante
afluencia de personas en lugares
públicos
la ciudad china de wuhan vive bajo la
nueva normalidad cuando se aproxima el
primer aniversario desde el inicio del
brote de kobe 19 desde mayo no hay
reportes de casos transmitidos
localmente pero aún quedan numerosas
preguntas sobre el origen del virus por
lo que un equipo internacional realizará
una investigación independiente
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez iniciamos este informativo
en reino unido- porque desde este
domingo 20 millones de británicos
quedaron confinados al menos durante 10
días luego de que se descubriera una
nueva cepa de coronavirus que estaría
fuera de control el ministro de salud
mat hancock indicó que las nuevas
restricciones buscan evitar otro
confinamiento nacional
la nueva variante está fuera de control
y necesitamos controlarla y esta noticia
sobre la nueva variante es
increíblemente difícil y francamente ha
sido un año horrible y es importante que
todos actúen como si tuvieran el virus
y es inevitable que nos dirijamos hacia
otro confinamiento nacional
no necesario bueno no necesariamente y
una de las razones con las que
implementamos las restricciones del
nivel 4 diciendo quédense en casa y
quédense localmente donde quiera que
estén en reino unido es justamente para
tratar de evitar la expansión de esta
nueva variante
jones stoke this new the rings
continuamos en europa donde varios
países han impuesto nuevas restricciones
en el periodo previo a la navidad a
medida que aumentan los casos de kobe 19
en londres y el sureste de inglaterra se
han encendido las alarmas tras la
identificación de la nueva cepa del
virus pues los científicos dicen que se
está propagando más rápido que las
variantes anteriores a continuación un
resumen de las últimas restricciones
decretadas en el 'viejo continente'
en el reino unido se ha identificado una
nueva cepa de coronavirus que se está
propagando a toda velocidad
boris johnson había prometido que la
navidad no se cancelaría pero tuvo que
cambiar de opinión
no podemos continuar con la navidad como
estaba planeado en inglaterra quienes
viven en áreas de nivel 4 no deben
mezclarse con nadie fuera de su propio
hogar en navidad de rangel show esto
efectivamente restringe las reuniones
familiares para millones de británicos
que viven en londres y en el sureste
inglaterra también en el continente hay
nuevas medidas estrictas en este
restaurante en berna suiza es el último
servicio de cena en un mes las
autoridades han ordenado que los
restaurantes y gimnasios cierren durante
30 días en italia las tiendas no
esenciales cerraran y se les pedirá a
las personas que se queden en casa
estamos imponiendo una zona roja en todo
el territorio nacional entre el 21 de
diciembre y el 6 de enero estará
prohibido viajar entre regiones 3 al 6 y
nadie en españa aumenta la preocupación
por una posible
o la de infecciones en madrid' sólo
pueden reunirse grupos de seis personas
en comparación con las diez permitidas
inicialmente no poder estar con todos
nuestros seres queridos en estos días
tan especiales pero hay que pensar que
es mucho más importante evitar los
contagios evitar la enfermedad evitar al
fin y al cabo del comil 19 los cierres
de navidad' también están en vigor en
austria y república checa- tras
conocerse esta variante del comida en
reino unido países bajos anunció la
suspensión de vuelos británicos por lo
menos por el resto del año luego de que
se confirmara un caso de contagio con
esa nueva cepa del virus en territorio
neerlandés a la medida se sumó bélgica
que también congeló la llegada de vuelos
y trenes provenientes de ese país por su
parte del gobierno de alemania indicó
que estudia seriamente interrumpir la
llegada de aviones desde reino unido
vamos a américa latina porque ciudad de
mexico y el adyacente estado de mexico
vivieron este sábado su primer día bajo
el denominado semáforo rojo con la
intención de frenar el auge de la
pandemia se trata de una medida que
implica el cierre de todos los negocios
no esenciales pero que no impidió que se
vieran imágenes de multitudes en las
calles desde el gremio de los
comerciantes ya hablan de millonarias
pérdidas mientras el país acumula más de
117 mil fallecidos mundiales nos da más
detalles
así lucían las calles de ciudad de
mexico el viernes justo antes del
comienzo del mero aislamiento
así se veían ese sábado bajo el semáforo
rojo que impide el funcionamiento de los
negocios no esenciales en ambos casos es
evidente una importante afluencia de
personas en las calles pero esta vez
algunos sienten que el momento no es el
adecuado por un lado está bien pero
también por otro lado es que me pongo a
pensar no a todos los trabajadores y
demás que en estas dos semanas pues no
van a pueden perder trabajo además las
asociaciones de comerciantes estiman que
esta restricción que irá hasta el 10 de
enero va a generar pérdidas por 2.400
millones de dólares y alertan de un
escenario que podría llevar a ocho de
cada diez en restaurantes a la quiebra
el gobierno central y local se escudan
sobre todo en la ocupación hospitalaria
que en ciudad de méxico es del 85% algo
nunca antes visto en ningún momento de
la pandemia
el gobierno nos indicó que teníamos que
hacer nosotros no ve decimos entonces
ahorita estamos pagando las
consecuencias todos
tanto ahora así que personas que no
estamos en el ámbito comercial como las
personas que viven de ello es una
navidad con restricciones en esta zona
de mexico y conscientes de este panorama
las autoridades han reforzado operativos
como éste contra fiestas ilegales este
último se registró el viernes a las
afueras de la capital obras antes de la
entrada en vigor del semáforo rojo el
presidente de brasilia air bolsonaro
aseguró que no hay prisa por comprar la
vacuna contra el kobe 19 ni por
distribuirla porque según él la pandemia
está llegando a su fin
las declaraciones se producen pese a que
brasil es el país más afectado de
américa latina con más de 7 millones de
casos según bolsonaro las vacunas pueden
causar reacciones imprevistas en el
sistema inmunológico la corte suprema
del país decidió el jueves que el
fármaco será obligatorio pero no forzoso
autorizando a los gobiernos locales a
imponer sanciones para quien no lo haga
sin embargo el mandatario ha dicho que
no se vacunará
y se cumple casi 1 año desde que se
declaró el brote de kobe 19 en la ciudad
china de wuhan allí se vive un ambiente
de normalidad mientras los residentes
lidian con los recuerdos del
confinamiento desde mayo no se reportan
contagios locales y a medida que el 2020
va llegando a su fin
los lugareños reflexionan sobre lo
ocurrido
los asistentes a esta fiesta se corean
entre sí en la pista de baile con pocas
mascarillas a la vista empujan la vida
nocturna está de vuelta y en pleno
apogeo para este artista local es
difícil de creer que unos meses atrás
estaba cantando solo frente a una cámara
linda ahora estoy viendo este vídeo y me
doy cuenta de que estuve atrapado en
casa sin saber qué hacer
télam acm o el 31 de diciembre de 2019
las autoridades de salud de wuhan
publicaron el primer aviso de alerta
sobre un virus desconocido un mes
después la ciudad de 11 millones de
habitantes fue aislada repentinamente
del resto de china mientras entraba en
un estricto bloqueo de 76 días and yo
menga fue voluntario para ese entonces
enviaba comida a la gente que estaba
atrapada en sus casas
y en ese momento sólo podía comer una
comida al día no muchas personas se
ofrecieron como voluntarias así que
estaba muy ansioso era la tía oliva
algunos regresaron a sus lugares de
origen como jan con juan esta vendedora
de comida en la calle no tenía un
ingreso fijo pero ahora aprecia el
tiempo que ha podido pasar con su
familia
y sencillas ya a lo largo la pandemia
nuestra familia entera estuvo junto
fueron momentos muy preciados y estaba
muy feliz ya ese país más importa de
acuerdo con las autoridades en wuhan no
ha habido reportes de casos transmitidos
localmente desde mayo pero todavía
quedan muchas preguntas sobre el origen
del virus en enero del próximo año
después de meses de negociaciones un
grupo de científicos internacionales irá
a wuhan para realizar una investigación
independiente así finalizamos esta
emisión recuerden que pueden ampliar
toda la información en nuestra web
france24 puntocom y continuar con
nosotros esto es france24
[Música]